Let's take a look at another
simple use case where we create
a file that is going to have
both a named and a default
export. We're going to create a
user, where this module will
allow us to create a new user,
but then it will also have some
utility methods to get the URL
for that user's profile and
generate a base64 encoded
Gravatar URL. Let's go and
make a new file, and we will
call that user.js. Inside of
that, we have a function called
user. That will take in a name,
an email, and a website for the
person. Then we're simply going
to return an object that has
their name, has their email,
and has their
website.
Wes, Wes,
Wes, what are you doing?
Hopefully by now you're yelling
at me and saying, "Wes, if the
property name and the variable
that it's being sent to are the
same thing, we do not need to do
that." This is an improvement on
object literals. We can just put
them all on a single line and
return it there. Cool. Now we
have that function for the user.
Then let's create a function
called createURL. That is going
to take in someone's name, and
it's going to return to us
something like site.com/wes-bos,
assuming my name was Wes Bos.
That is a function, and we need
that slugify plugin that we
installed earlier. Let's
look at our package.json. We
installed this slug plugin. Now
I'm not inside of app here, but
if a module has a dependency on
it own, you just import it.
Import slug from slug. This one
doesn't need quotes around it.
Here what we are going to do is
return. Now we need that
base URL. Where's that base URL?
It's in our config. There it is,
so we can import that as well.
Import URL from config, don't
need the js. You see how we're
just deciding what we need? We
go into the file that we need
and just pluck the one item that
we need. Even though we
imported it into our main file
right here, API key and URL,
doesn't mean that it's available
in every other single module. If
you need something twice, you
need to import it twice. Don't
worry, Webpack won't duplicate
the code, it's smart enough to
just import it once. We have
this import right here, with our
return in here. We have our URL,
which is going to return the URL.
Then we want to do /users/ and
someone's actual name. We can
use the slug function, and pass
the name that we get passed in.
You see how we have a function
here that pulls in a variable
from another file, and a
function from an existing
package? We use that right
inside of there. Finally,
let's use a Gravatar, so
function gravatar. A Gravatar is
a globally recognized avatar.
You can get anyone's avatar if
you know their email. You just
have to base64 encode it.
How is this going to work? Well,
the way that a Gravatar URL
looks like is something like
this, photoURL = and it looks
like that avatar, but on the end
we have a base64 hash of their
actual name, so we need a base64
library. No problem, we'll go
grab one from npm and put this,
npm install base64--save. Npm
install base64--save installs
that module for us, and then I
can import it here. Import
base64 from base64. Now
let's take a second. Why can I
just do that? Well, the creator
of base64 package, sorry it's
base-64, has created it for us,
so that they have exported it as
a default. Then I can go ahead
and import it as anything I like.
In this case I'm using base64,
what we can do here is we'll say
hash = base64 email. We can make
this a template string and
pop in the actual
hash. Cool, so we have two
utility functions, as well as
the ability to create user name.
Now we've made this module that
does a bunch of stuff for us. If
we want to be able to use it in
other files, we simply stick
exports in front of them. This
is the main one, so I want that
to be default. I'm going to say
export default
function user, good. Then these
ones are just export and export.
These ones are named exports,
and this one is the default.
Now if I go back to app.js we
can go ahead and start using it.
I am just going to get rid of
this console.log, get rid of
this say hi, get rid of
everything in here. We've
got our imports and we are going
to import. Now how do we do a
default? We could say import
user from source/user. Good, but
what if I want to do named
exports as well? You could
simply do this. Comma, then do
your curly brackets, and we want
to import createURL and Gravatar
from those, and we're able to go
ahead and start to use them just
as we want. Let's try it out.
Let's first create a user object.
Const user = new user, and you
pass it Wes Bos first thing, and
the second thing we would need
to pass would be the email and
then the website, wesbos@gmail.
com and the website is wesbos.
com. Let's console.log the
user...Actually, let's not call
it user. Let's call it Wes, for
simplicity's sake. Now, you may
notice that this takes a little
bit longer this time, and that
is because this slug library is
fairly large because it does all
of the languages. You may want
to find a slimmer slug library
if you don't need all of the
features for it. If I open up
my index.html now, we should see
an object which has email, name,
and website. Good, I'm happy
with that. Now back here, let's
try the createURL function. We
say const profile = createURL,
and we are going to pass it wes.
name. Make sure you console.log
profile as well. Refresh, now we
have the actual URL. That base
is pulling from our config file,
and this slug is pulling from
the slug package that we used.
Let's try the other one.
Gravatar const image = gravatar
wes.email. We actually get an
error her on line 14 of user.js,
and it's base64.encode. The
method is encode, and then we
have to return the photo URL
from our actual function.
Console.log the image, and there
we see a Gravatar URL.
Hopefully that shows you how you
can use modules to make nice and
tidy code bases. Put your
functions inside of their own
files. Then if you ever want to
use these functions in other
files, you can put them on npm
yourself, or you could share
them amongst your coworkers, and
they are much more easily
testable.